Colin Kaepernick has got a powerful
message for younger people in his new
book he says stand up for what you
believe in now this comes almost seven
years after the former San Francisco
49ers quarterback started taking a knee
during the national anthem to protest
racial Injustice and police brutality
his new young adult book is called Colin
Kaepernick change the game details of
his coming-of-age journey in his
introduction to activism in high school
Adriana Diaz sat down with Kaepernick at
a Chicago bookstore for his only TV
interview about this book
please welcome Colin Kaepernick
the off season for Colin Kaepernick
looks much different these days the 35
year old has a non-profit you're already
creating Community empowering black and
brown youth a publishing company and
media projects including a docu-series
on Netflix and an upcoming documentary
with director Spike Lee he is also a new
father who's spreading a message of
empowerment in his new graphic novel
changed the game written with author and
University of Chicago Professor Eve L
Ewing I love how you depict yourself in
this book not as some big shot hero but
as a shy insecure high schooler like we
all were I mean I'm speaking for you but
growing up I was a uh I think still I'm
a pretty introverted person I hope it's
true to form and that's just kind of how
I navigate the world it's his true High
School coming-of-age Story his journey
embracing his Blackness despite
resistance from many including his white
adoptive parents I know my parents love
me but they were still very problematic
things that
I went through I think it was important
to show that no this can happen in your
own home and how we move forward
collectively while addressing the racism
that is being perpetuated he took cues
from his icon basketball star Alan
Iverson who he said wore his Blackness
like a suit of armor and teenage
Kaepernick wanted cornrows to match he's
getting what roles his mom asked oh your
hair is not professional oh you look
like a little Thug
said that to you yeah and those become
spaces where it's like okay how do I
navigate the situation now but it also
has informed why I have my hair long
today the grown-up version of Eve wanted
to go back in time and give young Colin
a lot of hugs and I was really moved and
saddened by the level of kind of
self-awareness that he had to develop at
a very young age without a lot of
guidance the former NFL quarterback who
once led the 49ers to the Super Bowl was
known in high school for his baseball
the pitcher even had Major League
interest but he bucked public pressure
and followed his heart to the Gridiron
there were a lot more black people in
football so I was like I found some
Community here do you still want to play
football professionally
absolutely
I woke up this morning before our events
trained
five six days a week I'm still up at 4
30. I go get my training in that passion
is still there and the ability is still
there he
sees it when this single gesture sparked
both solidarity and outrage why did you
choose that day and to protest in that
way that's actually something we're
going to dive deep into with the the doc
that's coming this fall but as it
relates to the book people may look at
that moment and be like oh you must have
been this person all along it's like no
there's growth that has to happen will
you continue to sit yes then Kaepernick
couldn't get hired and even sued the NFL
for collusion in a case that's settled
are you talking to any teams we reached
out to all 32 teams every year
throughout the year because my biggest
thing is just let me get on the field if
I'm not good enough
cut me but give me the chance to show
you what I can do in 2019 the NFL
organized a workout for you in hopes of
getting you hired
you chose not to go to their workout you
held your own workout what do you say to
people who argue that the NFL did give
you a shot that's another great question
that will be covered in that in 2020
what did it feel like for you
to see everyone almost wake up another
great question that will be covered
later this year Colin I got a lot of
great questions I I appreciate it
I won't speak for Colin but I think that
in thinking about what impact looks like
it's so much bigger than changing one
system or one League what does it mean
for all of us to be faced as we
invariably are with really tough
decisions about what it means to do good
in the world and how do we Inspire one
another to make different decisions when
that time arises for their next chapters
Ewing is writing the next Black Panther
comic I like real life superheroes and
pretend superheroes do you consider the
man next to you a real life superhero
the thing about superpowers is you got
to keep them secret part of the goal in
telling the story is no take pride in
your Blackness take pride in your
culture My Hope Is young people and
readers walk away and they seize their
power when y'all are in that position
you have the opportunity to change
things Kaepernick's story continues with
his advocacy
trying to return to the NFL Colin what
is it like for you all these years later
to be pushing and still not getting a
yes very similar to the messaging of the
book is I don't have control over all of
these situations but I control how I
respond to it I control how I prepare
for it I'm a believer that in doing that
good things will happen for CBS mornings
Adriana Diaz Chicago
okay well I want to I certainly want to
see the documentary because still there
are still so many questions and I want
to see the book and I think it's
interesting how many people's perception
have changed from 2016 when he first
took a knee to what has happened now as
we sit here in 2023 he was Raising some
very important issues that still exist
today that's right still exists today